sean put something on here that i
actually think i was telling
uh a friend as i was researching i
actually think that this is one of the
better ideas
that we and you you've ever come up with
the michael jordan thing all right yeah
you want me to explain it okay so
um i've been looking at this house for a
long time
michael jordan's house has been for sale
for like a decade and it hasn't sold
and this is his house uh kind of like
you know in illinois near chicago where
you know michael jordan was on the bulls
and he had this 56
000 square foot home in highland park
and so this thing originally he put it
up for sale
and like i don't know nine years ago for
30 million
29 million dollars and now it's you know
the price has been cut in half and the
thing is still not selling and if you
look at the photos you can just go it's
like on zillow
so you can go look at the photos he's
got like an indoor basketball court
you know the gate leading up to the
driveway has his big 23 number
like embossed in it he's got you know
everything you would want like
huge you know closets because he's got
you know all his air jordans or whatever
and so his house is it's pretty
unbelievable
right there's there's all kinds of um
epic [__] here
but it's not selling and it's not
selling for i think a couple reasons
it's like you know
it's very custom to michael jordan um
like it just it's like
it was custom made in many senses so you
know that other rich people don't
necessarily want to live in a house
that's like made for another dude
um it's also you know it's very
expensive for the area
the property taxes are really expensive
all that stuff but
i was thinking okay the price is now cut
in half now it's now it's a 13 million
dollar house or a 12
you know 13 million home that you could
buy
13 14 and now it's in range where
maybe there's something fun you could do
with it now you might be getting a value
buy so i was thinking
all right there's a bunch of people
obviously that are basketball fans that
love michael jordan
um there's a bunch of you know new ways
to crowdfund that we've been talking
about nfts or
uh kickstarter or different different
crowdfunding platforms so
the question is should we buy michael
jordan's house
should we start a crowdfunding campaign
and buy michael jordan's house so if you
could get
5 000 people to each put in 2 500
then you can own a fractional share of
michael jordan's house uh you could you
you could own a piece
of of this history and we could just buy
it out take it off the market
um and we could own this thing and then
the question is like what do you do with
it
um and so i wanted to brainstorm with
you a should we buy michael jordan's
house and b
what could we do with it if we did buy
it what do you think
so the whole nft thing i wouldn't do
that
i think that i think you've had two
ideas here one is to buy his house and
two is to end
do the nft thing uh one of those ideas
is great i think the other one is
over complicating it i would 100 buy it
and the reason why i think it's such a
great idea is
immediately after you seeing you write
this my
thought right away went to graceland you
know what graceland is
no that's funny that you don't know what
that is it's because it's such a big
deal
in my family or elvis is at least so
graceland
is elvis presley's house uh it's in
memphis it's in downtown memphis it's
actually in a pretty crappy neighborhood
now
or the neighborhood is not nice and it's
like
kind of gross but it's just like a
cutesy thing to do if you visit memphis
and i went and did research on it and so
around
600 000 people a year go to graceland
which brings in something like where i
have the numbers here okay so graceland
just in attendance uh just in ticket
sales brings in 21 million dollars
so it's yeah pretty wild just on tickets
and then 600
000 visitors a year uh 36
a ticket right yes and i got interested
in this so i thought
what are the most visited homes in
america so i came up with a few and i
want to
fill you in on them so the white house
doesn't count because you can just
you i think you can get a tour but you
could also just walk outside of it but
graceland
six hundred thousand the second one i'm
you guys are gonna make fun of me i
don't know how to pronounce this what is
it monticello
i think so okay monticello that's uh
thomas jefferson's house
and so the interesting thing about this
place as well as a few other i'm going
to mention is that they're non-profits
which means all of their numbers
are public and so uh the revenue for
monticello which
includes a ton of investment revenue was
around 200 million dollars
in 2010 but around uh 8 million
7 million came just from ticket sales so
8 million a year
in ticket sales which is crazy and they
have around 500 000 people
another uh most visited home is never uh
like homes that people drive by
neverland ranch people don't go there
but the other another great one is mount
vernon which is uh i think
uh what's our first president george
washington's house
uh and they do in
in in uh food sales alone
this is crazy just in food seventeen
million dollars a year
wow is that crazy the whole operations
and then they do 15 million dollars a
year in admission sales
and in total they do about 51 million
dollars a year
in total income which includes 10
million from contributions
is that crazy that no that's absolutely
insane so let me ask you
these okay so this all of a sudden this
starts to get really interesting right
because i think michael jordan is on par
with elvis and
you know thomas jefferson michael
jordan's got tj beat by a long shot so
you know mj over tj i think is is part
of the the slogan that we have
when we when we buy this thing but um if
they're doing this much
in traffic i got to know is there
something else meaning like are these in
really hot like
popular areas uh where there's already
just a lot of tourists or something like
that
and this is just a pit stop because you
know michael jordan's house is in a
neighborhood
you'd have to only be going to go to
this place
i looked up michael jordan's address
guess how far away it is from
chicago airport one of the most popular
airports in the world i'm gonna guess 45
minutes
20 minutes it's 20 minutes away
okay so it's at like have you been in
memphis memphis is like there's not that
much going on in memphis and all these
people are going to memphis um
people are chicago's what the fifth most
populous city in america
or maybe third something like that
something
is interesting here so what i would do
is i wouldn't do the nft thing
i would raise uh two or three million
dollars from a bunch of rich people
um or i would try to use my own money if
i had two or three million dollars that
i wanted to spend on this
and i would buy it and then it would
probably cost a fair bit of money
to get it set up it would probably cost
a lot of money
another many more millions but then
you'd have to convince
collectors to lend you
the stuff and you create a michael
jordan museum yes
and that's how you do this and
the companies that we've just mentioned
graceland monticello
and um mount vernon so those obviously
those folks lived in the 1700s or
probably died in the 1800s so they've
been around those properties have been
around
as tourist destinations for a hundred
plus years
but they've done 50 million revenue
which is a [__] ton but even if you've
just
um two or three million dollars in
revenue and you could do that and adjust
for inflation for 50 plus
years kind of like graceland has done it
for 60 years that's incredibly
fascinating
right yeah i'm with you so so i think
you you know you're [__] on the nft
thing a little bit but it's not about
nft what i'm saying is
crowdfunding um so i think that there's
a benefit to crowdfunding which is that
crowdfunding is a way to make the story
more viral
um it is a it's a more pr worthy story
that
uh you know people from the internet
people from reddit whoever got together
and bought michael jordan's home off the
market for
for 15 million dollars they raised 15
million dollars and bought the house
versus a rich guy went to his rich
friends and raised some money the second
thing is those become
you know your evangelist to spread the
word and to come
make the uh the pilgrimage to go see
michael jordan's house
and i think you could do two or three
things with it i think you could make it
a museum that's like a modern museum
that we've been talking about like
the museum of ice cream or something
like that where
the tour is very heavy um photo based
and so you're you know you're going
through and it's all these different
photo exhibits
of you know you in michael jordan's bed
and you know wearing you know a pair of
his air jordans or standing in a pair of
giant air jordans or something like that
and you make it like a museum of ice
cream where
you're going to walk out with you know
10 photos that are instagram worthy
at the end of it i also think give give
people
background on an ice cream museum yeah
you can pull the latest numbers but i
think these guys uh raised it like a
hundred million dollar plus valuation
and if you if you ever go to one they're
pretty cool it's you know it's not the
most amazing thing i
honestly i was a little bit disappointed
but the photos do turn out cool it's a
museum that you walk through
uh so it's like a guided path and you go
through maybe like 13 different rooms
and every room is something cool and you
get a little you know you get an ice
cream cone of some flavor
and then you can take photos next to
some like exhibit that they've set up
and the idea is not for you to look at
the art like a traditional museum
but for you to like take a photo in the
art uh and post it on instagram and
that's their marketing that's the free
marketing that they get
and so museum of ice cream oh yeah here
everybody has it they raised 40 million
they raised a 40 million dollar series a
at a 200 million dollar valuation last
year
and um and i think this could be bigger
i think this could be much much bigger
as a brand
um the other thing the other thing that
you could
do is uh sports cards are having this
incredible boom right now
and i think what you could do is you
could have certain collectors
put their collection um in
in the house the house could be
basically the vault to store some of the
most rare
memorabilia in the sports world sign
basketball
shoes and sports cards and that could be
part of the museum and you you
basically store it and you um you store
it for some of these collectors so i
think
i think there's a bunch of stuff you
could do to make this work but the idea
is like
can you buy this thing for 13 million
put another four or five million into
uh you know getting it all set up and
then could you make five million dollars
a year could you make 10 million dollars
a year like you're saying these other
guys do
um as a pilgrimage for you know tourists
going to chicago and basketball junkies
i think the answer is definitely yes and
i think it's so
interesting um i found a i found another
example of one
and it's called the um it's called the
national trust for historic preservation
and it's a non-profit and all they do is
buy
um historical buildings and
their historic i looked at their numbers
they've been doing like 50 or 60 million
in revenue for years
and i'm still trying to figure out how
to entirely read
uh nonprofit statements but they have a
buy a line item that's revenue
less expenses which i guess that just
means prop i mean i don't know how they
define
yeah i don't know how they define either
of those
but it was 26 million and it's been
doing that for years
is that nuts so i like this idea i like
this idea a lot and i kind of want to
dig a little further into how these
um homes home museums work because i
think this is pretty interesting the
other good thing about this by the way
is that the basketball hall of fame
sucks uh nobody cares about it nobody
goes to visit it
um all the other sports like you know
canton for football
these are like tourist destinations you
know tons of people go there every year
it's really cool
and the basketball one is known to be
super lame
because they let way too many people in
and um and it's not
like it's not a thing that basketball
fans really care to go do
can i give you two more examples that we
what we could consider doing instead of
even doing a museum
maybe this is even simpler yeah so i'm
staying at my friend jack's house
it's a badass house um five
doors down or ten doors down something
like that
nearby is what's they call it the obama
house
and when obama was in office from uh
when was he in office
oh the oh the second the second term
um or whatever it was he would stay at
this house
down here and the owners let them stay i
think for a massive discount
now it's like it has its own wikipedia
page and it's called like the obama
house
and it sold 10 years ago for 7 million
after he had already stayed there which
sorry 7 million i said i say seven for
seven million
which is a lot of money but they rent it
out right now on airbnb for six thousand
dollars a night
or if it's booked all the way up 180k a
month
and it's branded as the obama house
i think that you could absolutely crush
it with a jordan
airbnb house would you and a group of
friends be willing to pull together
three thousand dollars a day to stay
there maybe i think the way you'd have
to do it
is you'd have to make it like a vegas
alternative
for bachelor parties and stuff like that
birthdays it's like
what is the man cave man dream vacation
it's like dude we're gonna go stay in
michael jordan's house
14 of us are going um and it comes with
like all the amenities and
you know all that stuff this is where
you go this is where you want to go
if you want to live like the sports fans
dream i think you could do that
i do like the museum one better what was
the second idea you had you said you had
two oh what wasn't the second
i guess it was more so uh just another
example the fresh prince of bel air
house
um it's it's kind of interesting but do
you remember living in san francisco
how there's like the what's it called
the painted ladies which is the whole
the full house house and then there's
the missed out firehouse
um i would just want to buy all these
and turn them all into twitter so i
lived a block away from the
uh from the full house house and uh
literally 24 7 there is somebody
standing outside of that house during
the daytime
uh taking a photo of it so there's just
a constant and it's not like
it's not like a huge line of people but
there's always like four people standing
outside taking a photo in front of the
full house house
every single day for the whole year it's
kind of crazy and then it just sold
actually
and it sold at basically like i think
1.5 or 2x
the market rate in that area so um they
got basically like a double
premium because it is the full
househouse which i think is you know
kind of interesting
um but okay i think we should uh i think
we should buy michael jordan's house i
think we should crowdfund
uh i think we should crowdfund five
thousand people together we should own
this thing
or we could go to rally road and we
could say hey rally
let's put michael jordan's house on
rally and uh
you know let's sell this baby out i
think if five thousand
right now with if you go on rally roads
you'll get two thousand or three
thousand people buying
a fractional share of you know a pair of
jordans or a signed autograph or a
signed rookie card or something like
that
[__] all that let's own the guy's house
so i think you could easily get 5000
people on rally road
to buy a fractional share of michael
jordan's house i'm surprised they don't
already do this
if they're listening to this uh you know
go go for it just give us credit
and give me a share of the house
i actually think that they wouldn't do
that because how do you liquidate that
it's been on the market for 20 or
how long 10 years no one is obviously no
one's buying it
so like how do you get liquidity from
that after seven years i don't think you
don't i think
the game here right the point of rally
is that they take things that are not
assets and they make them not liquid
assets they make them liquid assets so
because you can own a fractional share
now there's liquidity
any one person who owns a piece of
michael jordan's house can swap it for
anybody else who wants to own a piece of
it so you don't need a 15 million dollar
buyer
because you can sell them in blocks of a
thousand or fifteen hundred dollars
and so when you bring that price point
down there's people who
want to own a piece of the a piece of
the art a piece of the asset
which is how they do like you know
they'll sell
um you know a harry potter first edition
signed you know set of books and uh you
know instead of selling it for 25 000
they'll get you know 2 000 investors to
each put in or whatever whatever the
math comes out to
150 bucks to go buy uh you know to own a
piece of that thing
so they introduce liquidity by making it
fractionally owned
yes but there's still no cash flow you
have to create an operation around this
cash flow and there's no cash flow in a
basketball card there's no cash flow and
air jordans there's no cash flow and
harry potter first asian investor who's
willing to buy it
no dude you're still thinking like the
old world you haven't seen what's going
on rally you're staying with jack smith
you should go ask jack smith about how
this stuff works
uh he's the one who who taught me and
he's one of the biggest investors in
this stuff
he's not buying it for cash flow um you
know he's buying it because
yeah there are there is another there is
another collector and when you make it
fractional
now way more people can get in on
collecting it versus
just the rich deep pocketed people who
could buy the whole asset 100 percent
yeah bro but who lik who liquidates it
after a
handful of years on rally road uh
someone actually buys the car
after a few years very rarely
occasionally somebody comes and offers
to buy out the whole
the whole lot um and then they put it to
a vote i don't know if you've seen this
but like you know let's say a box of
pokemon cards went on there
uh like a super rare pokemon card set
they i don't know what the ip what the
ipo was but on rally the ipod
let's pretend it was 50 000 and then
what happened is a is a big you know
asian investor came in and said we'll
buy this thing out for 85 000 now so
you'll all get a profit
but we want to own this thing and they
put it to the vote of all the share
owners and they said no they said we're
going to hold it we think it's going to
go up
so they voted no they voted to keep it
so they're not all trying to liquidate
um soon you know some some people who
are buy and hold investors will
want to own these assets for a long time
because they think hey you know if i
just hold this now
you know what's michael jordan going to
be what's michael jordan's fame going to
be
20 years from now if michael jordan
passes away how much is it going to be
worth
and there's people who are in it for the
long term so
i think there's i think the collectibles
thing is a little bit different than i
think about it differently than you do i
would say
you basically need jordan to have like a
tragic accident
or like for example dance came out so so
the last dance is ten part documentary
that came out
on netflix and espn um you know millions
and millions of people watch this thing
and jordan's brand you could see all the
price of jordans went up
jordan's like brand visibility and brand
sentiment went up
because this documentary came out and
he's still alive it wasn't a tragic
event
but somebody told the jordan story to
the the younger generation who
you know grew up with you know they were
two years old when jordan was at his
prime
and so jordan brand got stronger with
the last dance coming out
and i think that's just going to
continue you know over time because he's
got all these different you know
the legacy becomes bigger than the
person itself but i have a different
thing that's
sports related okay
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like the road